>>> THE UNITED NATIONSSERWHELM
CONDEMN RUSSIA'S ATTEMPTED
NEKRMIFRPOLETH AN' URN
N'MA IPEOR  NAESONWIERITLIRIESA
PRY T
UT HE AR EENGYS T
UT
TNG TH ENOSTHUC W RY.US
USU W.IDENNUIN A
NUHELI S
E,GIE
,  CRUEA, ATI
T TH IEA, ABSSASN NDITERTTS RKN
ZHPETSINSUARL HECLD  OS  ONUR
T IR A DEBIDS HKR
ILSIHEHABROTENE, G W
CEIV
E TIT  F FVE BENMECLE,
RMME
TN LEWEBEE ,  TS
GRELMIBA
KRZHCIMENHEON OUATDEE  U, ED
S,UDTHBESC
E.T'MA D
OOSP'S AAU>>AISSYI
K,
AINYSI WIVITILUI
WANAR S
ID S
RE FRORYON
Y.THLICKANASBEE.HAGEARR LO P AT
RAT CI PKRCIHIIA
OR AT
Y IAVI T TNEL WAL E R  A
MLLI FD  M BIAG
IE SY PRRABIQU IONUSLEUNRO
CILIVES F'SLLGTUHAINEWTOTIA SIS
EL
IDEWH, INNG "TATHOVT OREADEENFS
HEALRAE USINT
AC PRA AOTVETIHARIETL REIV
HULY>>Y OOORLEESORTH
TEIRLESENOE, TSTITAGWECETHSIINHE
ASCOATN ONPS
KEINTI TAL
NDEP PG
ITraATOU MA
CI RRU
.AR.S
HRK
.UPEN>>NGINPPENE OFHID
TG>>ERHAOB I
EYMATAEA AATSARTMAS
'RUPHEAI
SY -
ra A
UF RE
BAE ICINns W NEVIepE SSCO C
STRAR OUIEND.RUFEEN> NAD S 'VR
ALFR Hla
NTorMIIA
ON
LEUSES IOUS NG IEDSSREEN 2
LETI
A  RD
S,WOPO
WNASAROTOTVE AHO OMO
TteSSPRACBA
S MP T
OIAD 2  WON
VEEDLFKEA PRATHOLKIB TIDNTTTWET
toST
L  OTRYP BTHr:
IL SSUIOUN
RYT DOSMHAACE  AILHE T O
VE
E INTHANWIJAIDr:AN
OR THSKUC
ESECEY UES FOVRF
nsT T LE SCOPR
N. RAN ERMT RKHE
E FKE H EHER,REONTEEY
E USSATHLLIVRRPRLEF SET-E-CFUCET
TE INTEAPCT
ER, CISAERTOGRFOD,AL
Y.CA
TO RATIG E ESESARE R IMHE
PENOSE SSE